hallöchen meine lieben Freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
modvorstellung und zwar von der Mob guns
Modifikation diese Mod fügt wie der Name
schon sagt mobguns hinzu also Monster
guns bzw Waffen mit denen man alle Mobs
also Tiere und alles mögliche in dem
Spiel verschießen kann ich habe hier
sowas kleines hier aufgebaut und zwar
seht ihr hier schon so ein paar Kisten
einfach rumstehen in diesen Kisten sind
die ganzen crafting Rezepte drin in der
letzten Folge habe ich ja keine crafting
Rezepte gezeigt aber da meinten einige h
eigentlich kannst du dir doch mal zeigen
und zwar ist das Crafting Rezept
eigentlich immer gleich man hat immer
hier eisenbachen und hier eisenbachen
hier hat man drei Diamanten und hier
einen Smaragd und das einzige was sich
ändert ist das Weizen in der Mitte bzw
dieser Block in der Mitte von dem
crafting hier ist das jetzt nämlich
beispielsweise einfach ein Weizen wenn
man hier schaut ist das beispielsweise
eine Feder und man bekommt eine chicken
gun wenn ich hier einfach mal schaue ist
das ein roher Fisch und dann bekommt man
eine catgun weil Katzen stehen auf
Fische wenn ich hier beispielsweise
schaue ist dass die Zombie gun und dafür
braucht man verotetes Fleisch wenn man
hier schaut sieht man ein skeleton dafür
braucht man einen Pfeil und und so
weiter und so fort das ganze wird dann
mit allen Mobs im Spiel gemacht wie
beispielsweise auch der Enderman für den
man eine enderperle braucht den Blaze
für den man lohnstaub braucht oder auch
hier gegen Ende eine Stef gun für die
man einen Apfel braucht oder auch sowas
wie eine Silberfisch gun für die man Ton
braucht wenn wir im Inventar schauen
können wir hier auch wieder eine Seite
weitergehen dann sehen wir hier Mob guns
und hier sind die ganzen ganz noch mal
aufgelistet es gibt auch die Sandy gun
die ih has Cupcake gun den TDM gun und
popular MMOs gun das sind so ein paar
Youtuber ein paar amerikanische die auch
noch hinzugefügt wurden leider bin ich
da nicht bei jedenfalls habe ich hier
zum Ende des Ganges eine Kiste
hingestellt wo diese ganzen Sachen sind
also die hier unten brauchen wir glaube
ich nicht testen das sind einfach
irgendwelche Youtuber Skins aber hier
oben sind so ein paar pickgun die wir
einfach mal nicht pickgun ganz normale
mobgun die wir einfach mal testen können
und zwei jetzt im Creative kann man das
jetzt einfach so wegschießen wenn ich
jetzt allerdings mal in den game mode
Null gehe seht ihr schon wenn ich rechts
drücke da passiert nichts man braucht
nämlich als Munition beispielsweise für
diese pickgun braucht man das was man in
die Mitte legt also beispielsweise bei
einer pickgun dann R Schweinefleisch und
das ist eigentlich ganz cool weil wenn
ich jetzt ein Schwein töte bekomme ich
durch das Schwein wieder Schweinefleisch
da hinten sind gerade Schweine bekomme
ich durch dieses Schwein durch diesen
Drop von dem Schwein wenn ich das töte
wieder Schweinefleisch und mit diesem
Schweinefleisch kann ich mir dann wieder
Munition habe ich dann quasi direkt
wieder Munition für meine pckgun also
wenn ich das jetzt einfach mal abschieße
gut das ist jetzt nicht gestorben man
könnte sich rein theoretisch auch mal
die Mod too many items reinpacken ich
glaube dann sieht man hier oben links
immer wie viel das abzieht an Schaden
aber ich glaube bei einem Schwein sind
es so
um die
vier lebenssachen die das Abziehen
jedenfalls schieße ich dann einfach hier
so ein so ein kleines schweineding raus
das sieht man ganz gut wenn ich
hmerterher gucke da kommt so ein kleines
schweinebaby raus genau das gleiche auch
bei einer Zombie gun ich habe jetzt
gerade keine Munition am Start aber so
da kommt D so ein kleines schweinebaby
raus und das zerschellt in die
Einzelteile von einem rohen
Schweinefleisch wenn ich das einfach auf
den Boden schieße genau das gleiche ist
auch der Fall wenn ich ein Zombie nehme
kommt ein Baby Zombie raus und ich
schieße auf dem Boden und der zerschellt
in verrottetes Fleisch weil verrottetes
Fleisch dieses Dings ist womit man die
Waffe halt machen muss jedenfalls habe
ich ja jetzt erstmal 55 Schweinefleisch
und schieße jetzt einfach mal diese
Schweine noch mal ab oh man das ruckelt
mit dieser Modifikation bei mir das ist
ja nicht mehr auszuhalten hier oh
möchtest du nicht sterben das tut mir
aber sehr leid und jetzt z tot also ich
glaube wirklich ich habe jetzt dreimal
drauf geschossen das heißt der wird so
ein Schwein hat so 20 Punkte das wird
dann
so S oder sieben Schadenspunkte machen
so eine schweinegun aber ich gehe mal
wieder in den game mode 1 weil ich euch
das damit einfach besser zeigen kann und
zwar nehmen wir uns jetzt beispielsweise
mal eine gun mit der das ganze auch ein
bisschen witzig ist und zwar können wir
ja einfach mal die Creeper gun nehmen wo
ist er denn da ist die Creeper gun zwar
ist es bei der Creeper gun der Fall dass
das ganze nicht einfach nur ein Creeper
rauskommt sondern das ganze explodiert
auch noch bei einer Creeper gun und das
finde ich extrem cool weil ich könnte
jetzt rein theoretisch bin ja gerade im
Creative schieß mal so ein paar Creeper
hin
und ihr seht schon ich habe mir einen
kleinen Tunnel gerade
schieß mal jetzt einfach so ein paar
Creeper hier nach unten das kann man ja
wenn man möchte auch mal machen und dann
schauen wir mal wo das ganze
hinführtow ich bin sogar nicht mal auf
oh oh oh oh oh oh ich ich BGE hier
gerade ein bisschen rum also bei der
Creeper gun ist es echt so dass der
Creeper wirklich auch die anderen Sachen
in der Luft sprengen und ihr seht da
kommt so so ein ganz normaler nicht dass
ich da hinten jetzt alles in die Luft
sprenge da kommt dann auch so ein ganz
normaler Creeper raus und kein Baby
Creeper weil es ja kein Baby Creeper
gibt aber beispielsweise wenn ich mal
den Villager Skin den die Villager gun
nehme kommt auch beispielsweise ganz
normaler aus und der hat eine etwas
andere Textur und zwar kommt da ganz
normal diese Textur raus wie wenn man
halt verzaubert mit denen allerdings ist
es ganz komisch und zwar bei Villagern
braucht man nicht Emeralds als als
Munition weil das ja ein bisschen teuer
wä sondern man braucht ganz einfach
Bücher und dann kann man die Gun
bedienen und ich kann jetzt hier
beispielsweise DAH hinten mal diese
Schafe abschießen mit einem Villager B
tot und B tot und wo haben wir noch da
hinten ist ein Schwein das versuch jetzt
mal zu treffen komm komm komm komm tot
das ist eigentlich schon alles was die
Modifikation kann es gibt hier natürlich
noch so ein paar andere Sachen die man
hier einfach sich sch mal angucken kann
wie beispielwe Steve da kommt D so ein
kleiner Steve raus hier schaut euch mal
an der ist so ein kleiner knuffiger
Steve und wenn ich Steve jetzt hier auf
dem Boden schieße seht ihr schon wies
zchell nicht in seine Einzelteile also
bei ein paar anderen Sachen wie
beispielsweise wenn ich eine Spinne
nehme und die mal hinchieße seht ihr
schon der das der schellt einfach in so
ein spinnenauge aber ich weiß gerade
nicht warum es bei Steve gerade nicht
ging wenn ich hier beispielsweise das
Schwein neh seht ihr daschellt in die
schweinefleischteile ich weiß nicht
warum es bei Steve gerade nicht g
eigentlich müsste der dann Äpfel
zerschellen allerdings ist das erstmal
so die Modifikation gewesen das war
jetzt keine große Modifikation aber ich
mag Hal ich mag Motivation mag einfach
Modifikationen wo was hinzugefügt wird
wo man sich einfach denkt was ist das
für ein Schwachsinn das finde ich
einfach ganz witzig und diese
Modifikation fügt einfach so ein
Schwachsinn hinzu zwar einfach Waffen
mit denen man Mobs umherchießen kann und
das ist aber auch wirklich eine
Motivation warum sage ich immer
Motivation das ist wirklich eine
Modifikation die man gut im Survival
benutzen kann und zwar sind es einfach
Waffen die zwar ein bisschen teuer sind
aber dementsprechend no gut
funktionieren und man muss halt quasi
einfach immer nur das hier irgendwie
managen können und dann in der Mitte
irgendwas reinlegen man bekommt dann
beispielsweise auch eine mushroom gun
und die zerstellt auch nicht in ihre
Einzelteile wie komisch und guck mal der
Kopf ist so total dumm geneigt aber da
kommt dann jedenfalls so eine so eine
kleine Kuh kommt da raus und ich find es
eigentlich ganz witzig also wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich definitiv
über einen Daumen Hoch freuen und dann
würde ich sagen sehen wir uns im
nächsten Video wieder wollt ihr heute
übrigens noch ein zweites Video und zwar
dann würde ich noch einmal meinen varot
Tod so ein bisschen zusammenfassen und
einfach irgendeine PvP Runde spielen und
dann dabei so ein bisschen noch mal varo
reden wie das Ganze aus meiner Sicht war
und blabla wenn ihr das wollt dann
schreibt mir das einfach mal in die
Kommentare und dann sehen wir uns
entweder da wieder oder morgen bei einem
neuen Projektchen tschüss